what I've thought of [ __ ] boy big snoop
d-o-double-g and this game is called
build your squad so what I'm gonna do is
build my ultimate Laker squad I've been
a Laker fan since 1977
some of you want bunny born I got $15 to
pick my ultimate Laker squad show you
how to GM you understand me to really
get you general management on first
thing I'm gonna do it take a dollar
right spinning o Eddie Jones let me tell
you what cuz me and Eddie Jones got the
same birthday
so me and Eddie Jones got the same time
he understands is dynamic and being a
team player Eddie and you only cost you
the dock so that leaves me with [ __ ]
idiot
so it's cuz Eddie's gonna be playing the
two so to speak I'm gonna go ahead and
make this move right now one two three
oh five greatest leg of all time Mac
I've never been a greater performance by
the other man and the reason why I'm
taking magic is because he's the best
flow generally he runs the flow he knows
how to get everybody involved
he just makes the team better and my
money then gotta low I'm definitely
gonna need a three-point shooter
very efficient and if you look official
you made that shot with 0.3 seconds left
so I may have to get something billion
in the nick of time how much money I got
oh you're making this hard
oh you're making this hot oh you're
making this hard and you're making this
hard I need a few more dollars man hey
Kareem just came to my walk of shame man
what we running this my man man all
right all right all right I'm gonna be
lawyer man one two three four five the
captain
I need that Scylla I got $2 left to get
me a good plate oh I know what I'll do
I'll take a dollar Robert holy
and then I'm gonna take another dollar
on normal necklace you can back up so I
got a starting five what a six man
coming off the bench I know how to work
this 15 now let's see that's general
management 101 take $15 from the month
I'll make it happen you're not getting
this 15 back either your counsel - so
here we go with my squad that I built
for y'all right before your eyes
we got Eddie Jones Derek Fisher Magic
Johnson Kareem abdul-jabbar
big game Rob and they're coming off the
bench
we got my main man no I'm Nixon so that
way my point boys can breathe you see
them guard relevant and then you have it
build your squad with big Snoop Dogg you
can also go get my off right now I want
to thank me it's out everywhere this is
Bleacher Report's big stuff and we out
[Music]